No Republicans, generally Republicans have gotten weak.
I'll give you an example. I said, they're weak. They're timid.
They're spineless their visionless. I said that for a long time,
You know, we recently lost John Lewis.
I have nothing politically that I agree with John Lewis,
except that, and the first day in Atlanta,
I got a call to my radio show from then mayor Maynard, Jackson.
But I got to know Joseph Lowery, the SCLC. They all come on my program.
The mayor would come on my program, Hosea Williams,
when my favorite guest ever really close friend of Martin Luther King, Jr.
Uh, John Lewis, Andy young. And I don't think Andy liked me much,
but with all these guys,
I knew when I got to know their story and it was one of great courage and
conviction. And if you look at Selma to Montgomery,
if you look at fire hoses and dogs, and I learned this lesson,
you see the peaceful protests of that time.
They help make this a more perfect union.
They put it all on the line. Here's an interesting side note to this, you know,
because we watched the eulogy with Obama. This, uh,
the eulogy Obama gave it at the John Lewis, uh,
remembrance and all the politics that he brought up,
which I found outrageous. It just.
It was a political thing. It.
Was, it was awful.
But he talked about the John Lewis extension of the voting rights act.
And I'm thinking, well,
hang on a second because the guy that's leading your ticket, Joe Biden,
he ever corrupt, ever forgetful ever out of it. Joe Biden,
uh, well,
Joe Biden says his mentor and his dear friend was
Robert Byrd. The former Klansman, by the way, Hillary said it, bill said it,
Schumer said it. Pelosi said it. So the TA, so,
so former president Obama was talking about these historic bills that John Lewis
absolutely along with so many others bravely fought for and made us a more
perfect union. Not perfect. We still have a long way to go. But so,
and yet they're talking about act,
but the guy that's running actually supported the guy that
filibuster that historic legislation, people don't know.
And this drives me nuts every two years, every four years,
what do they say about Republicans?
It's every election cycle Republicans are racist, sexist, misogynist,
homophobic, xenophobic, Islamophobic. They want dirty air and water. Uh,
Paul Ryan lookalike. It'll probably be a Donald Trump look alike.
This year is going to take granny in a wheelchair after she's only eating dog or
cat food for a year and throw her over the cliff and the wheelchair that's every
two and four years. It is atrocious. I went through on Hannity this week,
a history of how this happens every two and four. Well, the civil rights act,
Lyndon Johnson needed, and the voting rights act, 80% Republicans,
80% Republican than the house and Senate.
And then you have the mentor of their democratic presidential
candidate praising the guy that filibustered that bill. I mean,
that's madness to me, that's the guy that went integration was coming up,
talked about, uh, uh,
kids and integration of school as a racial jungle that he was
worried about what Donald Trump says.
This is an actual quote. This is an actual quote.
So I think a lot of people are waking up to this.
And I think that's partly because suddenly, well,
suddenly people can see the clips online where in the old days you couldn't
really see the clips, right?
What do you think happened to the Republican's or to the GOP or to
conservatives that let this thing get so confused that the
reality of the history compared to the way it's portrayed,
is that purely just immediate concoction?
Or do the Republicans have some blame there themselves?
No. Republicans, generally Republicans have gotten weak.
I'll give you an example. I said they're weak. They're timid. They're spineless.
They're visionless. I said that for a long time. Uh,
when Republicans finally elected, well,
we finally got a Republican president that would repeal and replace Obamacare.
Well,
where were the Republicans that voted 60 some odd times to repeal and replace?
They disappeared and they never even had an alternative in place.
I had an alternative, you know,
either patient power or Cato Institute book by,
by Musgrave and Goodman that I read years ago,
or a doctor that I often put on my show, uh, Dr. Josh Humber,
who, who created in Wichita, Kansas,
a healthcare cooperative totaling 50 bucks a month, 24,
seven concierge care. He negotiates directly with pharmaceutical companies.
Guess what? 50 bucks a month for an adult,
10 bucks a month for a child doctor available 24 seven.
You walk out with the medicines at a 90, 95% reduced rate.
You add that with a catastrophic plan.
If God forbid you have a heart attack cancer or a bad accident,
they were all, they weren't ready.
And then the senators actually voted Republican.
Senator seven of them voted for the exact same bill.
They had voted for two years that they voted on two years prior,
just a straight repeal bill. Now, when it meant something,
it didn't mean anything. So I'm angry at them for that. Now,
in terms of Republicans allowing this, this false narrative to go forward,
I do it every election year. Dave,
I show the same clips is a 1998 Missouri radio
ad. I went through this this week. If you elect Republicans, you know,
across is going to burn or the James Byrd ad in 2000,
that that says it's like my father was killed all over again because George Bush
didn't support hate crime legislation, uh,
with this horrific dragging death of this innocent man James Byrd.
But George W. Bush did support the death penalty.
So he wanted the guy dead, you know, for that crime, but that in humanity,
that evil and you know,
or Al Gore goes before a predominantly African-American audience. And he's,
he changes his tone, his pitch, his cadence it's to me,
it's like really tries to sound like he's a preacher in a,
in a predominantly African-American church.
Get another wrong agenda for African-Americans.
They don't even want to count you in the census or Hillary Clinton.
Same thing that prominent predominantly African-American audience.
I don't feel no ways tired. I mean, what is this?
She's got hot sauce, Sean. She's got hot sauce in her bag. Don't forget that.
Oh, I do remember that. Yes, indeed. Indeed. Um,
or they're going to put you all back in chains.
So this is the playbook.
I told everybody as I started the year and before I went on
vacation at the end of the last year, it's coming, they will do it.
It's the playbook, dirty air, dirty water, racist, sexist, Masonic,
and straight on through. So it frustrates me about Mitt Romney, Mitt Romney,
the very same people he's now embracing are the very same people that said he
was a racist and a sexist misogynist.
So that's frustrating.
The same people he was running. He had, he had binders full of women. They said,
he's a massage Eunice. Now, now he's the hero. So is that.
By the way we're, women's women's resumes so we could hire them.
Okay. Jeez, sorry. I have a resume.
That doesn't make it into the tweets though. You know, Twitter it's short. So.
I wouldn't know I'm off Twitter, help Twitter prison.
For more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media instead of nonstop,
yelling out our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.